[Musique]
ce bâtiment étant des relais de l'action
sociale du sud le ccs qui a reçu le
département et au sens de trois grands
secteurs d'activité la vie sociale et
solidaire l'enfance et la famille et
enfin l'aide et services aux personnes
centre communal d'action sociale est un
établissement public de la ville donc il
mène la politique sociale sur la ville
cette visite ça nous permet également
parce que en fait pour pouvoir mettre en
place une politique sociale sur un
territoire donc la salle de la commune
il faut également du partenariat sera
également mobilisé mais les ressources
du territoire et le conseil
départemental chef de file de l'action
sociale et l'acteur privilégié pour nos
campagnes et dans cette démarche avec
500 employés et 15 millions d'euros de
budget les actions sont très diverses le
pst ou encore les paniers fraîcheurs
permettent d'aider les personnes les
plus fragiles mais d'autres actions de
proximité existent tels que les
résidences tournesol voisine du ccs
c'est vrai que le département nous a
accompagné les nous accompagner avec un
budget de 5000 euros par an pour pouvoir
faire fonctionner cette résidence le
département est également au niveau de
la résidence deux appartements deux
appartements qui sont des appartements
de relais c'est à dire si les familles à
un moment donné surtout a sorti de
l'hôpital n'ont pas de logement ont
peuvent un peu les héberger bon
une inclusion collective dans cette
résidence qui donne un cadre adapté aux
personnes âgées
ainsi la visite de gros louis figure de
saint pierre confirme le bien-être des
résidents ou les prêts la mairie pour le
popoli la meilleure photo titia terre là
est d'accord il est le même quel
restaurant manama les animateurs de
résidence sont ici des bénéficiaires du
rsa accompagné par le département
l'idée c'est de mettre en place des
ateliers en faveur des personnes de la
résidence autour de différents supports
mais également d'ouvrir ces ateliers ont
fait aux seniors de la ville met en
place pour que l'arabie continue malgré
l'âge un peu plus loin le restaurant est
tenu par du personnel en situation de
handicap
personne ne peut prédire l'avenir mais
le contexte montrent qu'une partie de
plus en plus importante de la population
est considérée comme fragile
[Musique]